oh this is fun
Republican investigators in Congress
have a new and slightly troubling
question for the FBI now why didn't the
bureau tell them that the guy who
triggered the russia investigation
actually had a multi-million dollar
connection to the Clinton Foundation
reporter Allison span has been
investigating Australian diplomat
Alexander Downer she now joins us to
discuss her article just published in
the hill tonight Allison great to see
you thank you okay so now this is like a
cast of characters it's like a mystery
novel but tell us about Alexander Downer
and his connection to all of this is
Papadopoulos character and why it's
important so if you remember in the
summer of 2016 Alexander Downer was the
one who came out with his evidence about
George papadopolis he said he had a
drink with him in a London bar and
Papadopoulos revealed to him that he
knew that Russia had some dirt on Hilary
or might have some damaging emails to
her so he's the one that actually gave
that information to his government that
got the shilling government to the US
government and that launched the whole
Russia probe into Trump Russia collusion
well now we find out that Alexander
Downer has a tie to the Clintons now
what of tie now he's in a bar in London
he runs into Papadopoulos that the
circumstances around how he ran into him
is interesting you addressed that
slightly in your piece great but now
fast-forward two months after he sees
him in that bar Australia brings us to
the FBI took two months that's kind of
interesting it's a two month but then
you find out that of Downer's connection
to the Clinton Foundation is he secured
them a grant for 25 million dollars from
the Australian government funded by
taxpayer dollars to go towards aids
prevention and treatment in Asia oh
that's great AIDS prevention I mean what
were they wrong with that so 25 million
dollar foreign money from Australia goes
to the Clinton Foundation now is there
any question about how that money was
used or whether it was fraudulently
obtained so there was an audit that was
conducted three years later and it just
wanted to basically go through and see
what that project had achieved now they
did achieve some great thing as things
as far as getting those children
the antiretroviral drugs that they need
in my otherwise not have been given a
chance to get but there were some
questions about the money in that case
and whether it was handled properly and
in fact the the report goes on to say
that it was so mishandled that was
actually detrimental to the project and
they were given a score of two out of
six for handling the money and there's a
lot of yeah now the effect of the
clintons two out of six that's actually
a high mark for them and handling
finances or ethics I just want to read
this is from the Clinton Foundation
audit some management weaknesses were
noted with Human Resource Management the
absence of readily available and useful
budget information showing exactly how
funds were spent and project monitoring
so that's a it's not a resounding plus
but the more important thing is why
wasn't this revealed that's a big grant
that's a connection to the opposition
candidate to Donald Trump he happens to
be in this bar he happens to meet this
Papadopoulos guy he happens to funnel
the information and he's not a minor
figure he's he's a well-known liberal
politician in Australia whose buddies
were the Clintons and I think that's
what a lot of members our Congress are
asking now we talked to Jim Jordan for a
story and he was shocked when he heard
this information so you brought it to
Jordy brought it to both congressional
committees who know they didn't know so
we actually brought this information to
these congressional committees who were
investigating this case they had no idea
the FBI did not disclose this
information to them so they're shocked
and they believe they want this to be
investigated and in fact Jordan said
that he wants a special second special
counsel because he as he says that the
FBI cannot investigate themselves this
is one more this is one more example
first you had the dossier being funded
by the by Hillary Clinton and the DNC
that wasn't revealed to the FISA judge
and now you have this well and there's
actually four pieces of information they
didn't reveal the dossier was funded by
the DNC and Clinton Sidney Blumenthal
who is a close Clinton supporter was
funneling the information to Christopher
Steele through at the State Department
and then you had the Yahoo article that
was quoted in the fights application was
written by a Michael Isikoff who got his
information from Christopher Steele and
then now we have this connection between
Alexander Connor and the Clintons now
backwards really fun I know it's it
I know the Russian investigation is very
complicated but yes we have four
instances now although where piece of
information came from okay at least knew
the clintons just for fun this guy's sam
nunn burg we totally out of time but sam
Nonnberg is that you worked for the you
know he worked for the Trump campaign
for eight five seconds anyway he's
refusing to speak to Muller he was on
CNN earlier tonight and I'm sorry this
is too funny not to play to you let's
watch so Sam I have to ask you one other
thing yes ma'am and it's an awkward
question to ask but you know I've been
before you're sitting very close to me
yes we talked earlier about what people
in the White House were saying about you
yeah I don't know whether you you were
you were drinking or on drugs or
whatever they were but had happened
today talking to you yeah I have smelled
alcohol on your breath well I didn't
drink you have another drink so that's
not no so I I just because it is the
talk out there again I know it's awkward
let me just get give you the question
category mm-hmm thoughts it was painful
to watch I don't know how it react in
the situation like that but he's not
testifying for it I don't know him at
all I mean he was hired fired hired
fired I mean but he's not testifying
he's not talking to Muller sounds like
he could possibly be facing some jail
time if he refuses to trial court and
doesn't provide those documents so
should just another piece of the puzzle
for this has really bad halitosis or
something or he chews gin and gin and
tonic gum or something I couldn't it
could have been anything
Allison I hate to drag you on that mess
but I'm not that was what Allison spam
the hill I'm not drunk
that is the court of it I'm just kidding
great reporting you and something
fantastic